in a recent gum chewing contest violet
tried to blow the biggest blueberry
flavored bubble ever
every three seconds she added one piece
of gum to her huge bubble
on the graph below the x-axis represents
time in seconds so this right over here
is our x-axis
and the y-axis represents pieces of gum
in violet's bubble so this is the y-axis
right over here
plot points to show how many pieces of
gum were in violet's bubble after 36 and
nine seconds
so every three seconds she adds one
piece of gum so let me throw all my let
me let me throw all of my so what we
care is about three seconds
six seconds and nine seconds so every
three seconds we know that she adds one
piece of gum so after three seconds this
is zero right over here we're not going
to worry about negative time so after
three seconds she would have added one
piece of gum to her bubble
now if three more seconds passed by she
would have added one more now she would
have two pieces of gum in her bubble
and then if three more seconds passed by
now we're at nine seconds she would have
added one more piece of gum and now
we're at three total pieces of gum and
notice the ratio between the pieces of
gum and the time that has passed has
stayed constant because she's doing it
at a constant rate
1 to 3 is the same ratio as 2 to 6 which
is the same ratio as 3
to 9
so let's check our answer
very good